[Music]
[Applause]
mentioned uh Victor wama made his garden
debut last night and uh it was kind of
rough sailing there for the rookie Mike
Breen was on the call for the mothership
and NBA playby play commentator uh
Friday night he'll have uh well we start
that inseason tournament Mike will be on
the call Doc Rivers and Burke Lisa's
suters and Mike joins us now Mike thanks
for joining us what were your
expectations for wiim bayama last night
well first of I am so impressed how his
name just rolls off your tongue so
easily so I because it didn't work for
me it's like for some reason that name I
have to concentrate to say it and you
say it so beautifully it was like when
when Giannis came in it took me about a
half a season before I felt comfortable
saying a TMO and then finally I got it
and last night I'm I'm saying almost
like
wanyama because because I it just
doesn't I think I I said it wrong a few
times too so I'm I'm very impressed
there but do you ask the player how
often would you ask a player how to
pronounce his name um fairly frequently
um not like that one because that one
you know it's clear how you say it it's
just a matter of saying it correctly um
but there are a number of them that you
have to um for example and remember
Andre and ver yeah yeah played for the
Cavaliers good player very good player
yeah um he changed the pronunciation of
his name three different times during
the course of his career so first year I
said it one way and then the next year I
asked him and no it's different I said
is that the way you told me last year he
goes no no no this is really the right
way he was a lovely guy but he changed
it um so I do ask them frequently but he
he's not good enough to change the
pronunciation of his name three times in
his career no probably not but you know
sometimes it gets caught up in the the
American way to pronounce it and there's
still some people that say Dirk Nowitzki
as opposed to Dirk nitzki um it's also
confusing these are the hardships of my
job but you know what we waited until we
realized Giannis was going to be really
good because we would just call him The
Greek Freak and then all of a sudden
it's like you know he's going to be
around a while he's really good we got
to learn how to say
dumo exactly and I think I'm going to go
with w
uh next time I do a game all right so
what were your
expectations um I felt like a kid on
Christmas morning and this has only
happened you know a number of times all
these years where you just can't wait to
see somebody in person as as you know
watching a player and I think in some
ways basketball perhaps more than other
sports watching a player on TV and then
finally seeing them live are two
completely different experiences and
because of his unique build his size his
length I couldn't wait to see him and
you know obviously have high
expectations what you see he can do at
his size is you really feel this one has
a chance to be one of the all-time
special ones um and when you see him in
person you you're Blown Away by the size
the skill but he you know I just I
happen to be there for the wrong game
was probably his worst game um credit to
the Nick for part of it um but that's
what we're going to see from him we're
going to see one night like the 38 in
Phoenix and we're going to see a one for
n start at Madison Square Garden where
they just completely smothered him and I
think he was a little overwhelmed by the
moment which is okay for a 19-year-old I
mentioned this yesterday because here
you have Chad holgren out on the
perimeter with a handle you got Victor
one bayama what happens first if either
In Our Lifetime that we change the
dimension of the court or do we raise
the basket or KNE either I I don't think
I really don't think you have to do uh
either one I I I I I understand the
question and I I understand the
sentiment but uh nobody's completely
mastered the game that much yet I mean
there are some you know all-time great
players or once once in a generation
player but the game is still difficult
and even for for somebody like remember
nyama even for Giannis even for jic um
it's still it's still a challenge every
night and I don't see the need to at at
least in my lifetime I don't see the
need to to make any radical changes like
that is Chad hren a
rookie by definition yes by experience
no and it's interesting um that you
brought him up Dan is because you can
just see the difference from somebody
who's been around for a year who's been
in the NBA quote unquote Factory for the
year who's been to every Arena who's
traveled who understands you know Road
games who understands back-to-back
gam the call Friday night Lakers at the
Suns that's the the inseason tournament
help me get excited about this Mike
because I'm not excited about an
inseason tournament are you easily
excited well
um you know what when you say waiama
that gets me excited no when I say it
correctly um I I I root
for positive things with the NBA um so
yeah i' I'd like to be interested in
this I'm just trying to figure out how
interested okay first off plain and
simple the goal is to make a bunch of
regular season games just feel more
meaningful and bring about more
competitive spirit and I think there's
no question that's going to happen um so
much though depends on how much are the
players going to buy in like are these
games really going to mean more to them
because you'll be able to tell the
difference if it does okay um I go back
to the to the playing tournament when
they first announced the play in
tournament I'm like what are we doing
we've got enough people in the playoffs
we I love the play in tournament because
it matters it matters down the last
couple of weeks of the regular season
and it matters in those playing games
those playing games the intensity and
the competitiveness are as good as any
playoff game it's it's wonderful so I'm
thinking okay my I'm G to change and I'm
going to really come around to this
because I do believe if you get to your
your fourth in season Tournament game
and you have a chance to clinch and go
to Vegas and play in that knockout round
in the quarterfinals you're going to see
high intensity I I believe that and I I
kind of got that feeling even from the
first one I did last week with Dallas
and Denver um I just think that once
they have the chance to to qualify for
it once they have a chance to go to
Vegas and then they're thinking okay
half million dollars is not a bad uh
thing to get for it I think we are going
to see an increase in competitive nature
and I think there's going to be a better
interest I think they're plain and
simple they're going to be more
meaningful than if it was just another
regular season game how long before we
have an NBA team in
Vegas I think very
soon um it might even be just by the way
everything goes um with this in terms of
you know excitement and crowd and etc
etc I think um I think that might might
seal the deal I I know it's one of the
places they're looking although you know
places like Seattle so deserve to to get
an NBA team back I just don't know you
know how soon it's going to be um you
know we keep hearing they're talking
about expansion they're talking about
expansion I I think it's still several
years off yeah I wonder if this is when
LeBron retires and uh one of the gifts
he gets is to be part of a Vegas NBA
team feels like he's headed in that
direction yeah but again it's years away
because he'll play another 10 years for
sure
do you think he's officiated differently
I know that the Lakers complain to the
home office but do you think that
they're he he doesn't get the
preferential treatment maybe that he
thinks he still
deserves I I think anybody his size and
his strength uh often it's it's not fair
I'm not saying it's preferential
treatment but I just think you know when
you're an official and you're seeing two
bodies Collide and you're seeing contact
when the Conta is made against somebody
like LeBron size or a Shack or any of
those big men it just doesn't it looks
like marginal contact every call is made
is it illegal contact or marginal
contact when you're big and strong and
there's contact it always looks marginal
for crying out loud and I think all guys
that size and that strength it's
something they they kind of have to deal
with again not intentional not
preferential it's just by the eye what
the official sees and what what a lot of
us as well best team you've seen so far
is a tie between Boston and Denver uh I
know that's the obvious answer um but
the team that that that I I haven't seen
yet in person and I I said this last
year I think
OKC um has a chance one of these years
all of a sudden they're going to win 58
games I mean couple of years ago whe
they win 24 something Al along those
lines um they they're under something
yeah they are they got a terrific young
coach and uh they've got a a superstar
in Guild Alexander and they've got a
deep hungry team uh I really like them I
watched them the other night I really
like them a lot is Madison Square Garden
a great Arena or just a historic
place no I mean clearly historic but now
I mean let's let's face it i' I've lived
in New York my whole life I was a Nick
fon as a kid so I might not be the most
objective here when it's a big event
when it's a big game there's no
atmosphere like it there's some Arenas
that are louder loudest Arena I've ever
been in my life is the Old Chicago
Stadium uh and there's some more louder
there's louder ones now but in terms of
you know the old cliche of the
electricity in the building there's no
place like that that for me that's
number one do you remember your first
game at the
Garden first game I broadcast
grown up first game you went as a fan oh
yeah I was I'm gonna
say 12 years old 11 12 years old and I
actually I actually had a really good
seat because um my uh my little Le coach
took a bunch of us there and I just I
just was amazed at the size you know
again talking about watching on TV you
couldn't believe the size of the players
and then the next time I went I think I
was in the second to last row at the top
they look so
small what's the best game you ever saw
there either as a fan or
broadcast wow
uh I I'd have to say you know for me
again as a Nick fan um the game where
you know Patrick euwing uh won game
seven of the Conference Finals to to get
the Knicks back in the finals um and
then jumped on the on the scoreboard and
opened his arms like he was embracing
the whole crowd that was that was one
I'll never forget um but you know the
Michael Jordan Double
Nickel um you know what was some of the
great a couple of those Lin sanity games
I've never heard the building so loud
that was that was pretty cool too it's
impossible to pick one why do you ask me
questions like that I don't why are you
can tanker why are you grouchy just
because you can't pronounce mbayama it's
not my
fault d would say I wouldn't say grouchy
I'm just you know it's it's fairly early
you know I'm up late tonight I'm getting
ready for a flight to Phoenix and and
Umar for me for me to think clearly it's
just I'm getting old don't you
understand you do understand I know you
understand I know you
do safe travels to Phoenix Mike your
rough life there and I hope you survive
the Suns and the
Lakers thank you Dan thank you buddy
that's Mike Breen voice of the NBA for
the mothership in uh ABC